[Music]
Mondays coming up how are you guys
preparing is it rehearsing all weekend
are you taking any breaks we are
rehearsing as much as we possibly can it
is a huge workload and a lot of pressure
being here in week eight
vana is doing an amazing job I'm so
impressed with him every day in watching
how he pushes himself and allows me to
push him so but the stakes are high my
goodness it is week eight and everybody
is amazing and truly we are so grateful
to even be here in the week in the top
five and just so so grateful to everyone
that voted to get us through until for
all the love that we keep getting it's
so so incredible what can you tease for
us about my name oh my god it's going to
be exciting our trio is actually a lot
of fun I had a lot of anxiety about the
song it was really slow and really
groovy but somehow we've made it work
and Argentine tango is a different kind
of Argentine tango it's not your typical
men and women sensual chemistry it's
more a relationship between bonnet and
his adversities and the pain that he
faces every day and I represent those
adversities and pain so it's going to be
interesting